Mike's with us in Houston Texas hey Mike
welcome to Dave Ramsey show thank you so
much nice talking you too sir I have a
question I need some guidance me and my
wife are currently on baby step one we
should get that finished by the end of
this month not coming into baby step two
my wife would like to buy a new car the
current car she has um leo about $7,000
on it now
and I think he deserves a new car I
would like for her to have a new car but
I don't see how I can trade a $7,000
debt for a 20 or $30,000 debt so where
can I find some common ground like what
would you suggest that I do mmm well I
think we've got wrong goals and we've
got to reset our goals in your house and
that's your wife has the wrong goal when
you have the wrong goal the goal the
goal here needs to be and I in my
opinion you call them asked me so that's
what you gets my opinion the goal here
needs to be what is best for our family
long term and the best way to build
wealth and be outrageously generous and
have a high-quality life financially is
to become debt-free because not having
any payments all it gives you control of
your most powerful wealth building tool
which is your income I mean just think
about it if you had absolutely no
payments right now how much money you
would have otherwise
yeah and so that kind of proves my point
right there and you can have that same
discussion with her what if we had no
payments well we would be able to save
like crazy people and we be able to save
up and pay cash for a better car and
we'd be but it requires that we drive an
old car for a little while until we get
there not forever but we have to pay a
price to win you live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else but if your goal is to be
broke your whole life and look nice then
keep on the program you're on which is
go buy crap you can't afford with money
you don't have
yeah not only that I've even made a
suggestion I have a newer vehicle and
I've actually uh suggested you know
letting her drive my vehicle and I'll
take her listen I am NOT going to try to
placate a princess hey I'm going to sit
down with the princess and we're going
to start having grown-up discussions
here and I this is not a four-year-old
this is a grown woman and so we're going
to sit down and say what is best for our
life long term and let her join in the
discussion this one this is not a dumb
woman she just wants some nice stuff and
it's not a sad one nice stuff I want
nice stuff I drove down here in a nice
car today but I drove a piece of crap
for a while so that I don't ever have to
drive a piece of crap again and so
that's the thing I don't want you to
approach your relationship with your
wife of you're going to make her happy
by giving her crap you all can't afford
with money you don't have instead let's
approach it with let's have a dream of
being wealthy and incredibly generous
and being able to travel and being able
to buy a car or buy that pair of shoes
you like and and we've done that because
we built some wealth and the best way to
build wealth is honey think about what
if we had no payments Wow
that we could we could be able to do
anything we want to do if we had no
payments what's your household income on
forty hours a week I make about seventy
six thousand but I do get overtime so it
varies I think this year I'm on pace to
make about 120 good for you man you're
killing it you're working your butt off
with that congratulations how old are
you - I'm 31 she's 27
excellent very cool very cool well let
me do this I'll start the conversation
with you and then if you I'm going to
send you a copy of my number one
best-selling book that I've ever done
it's called the Total Money Makeover and
it crossed the bottom of every page it
says if you live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
in the Bible it says if you no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
it's never fun it's never fun to pay a
price but the only way you do
anything that is valuable in this life
is there's a price to be paid anything
that there's a shirt there's motion you
know Beverly Sills you say there's no
shortcut to any places worth going and
so you know it's just grown up stuff
adults devise a plan and follow what
children do what feels good and so if
you're going to just you you will never
make enough money to have any money you
cannot earn your stupidity as long as
you're trying to buy stuff to be happy
and so but get I'm not saying never have
some nice stuff but I'm saying for a
period of time let's pay a price and get
cleaned up and then with no payments
let's save like crazy and then buy that
car and pay cash for it and that puts
you in a completely different position
so hold on I'll have Kelly pick up we'll
give you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover if you want to go on
beyond that it's called Financial Peace
University it's a nine week class one
night a week for nine weeks and I highly
recommend the two of you go through that
but I don't think you're just your
conversation is at the stage yet you're
ready to have that conversation with her
so let's have some more conversations
first and then talk about maybe going to
a class but don't walk in and go talk to
this guy and he said don't buy you a car
that is not what we're talking about
here we're talking about her joining you
in an adult conversation about your
future and what is the best way to get
to that desired future what has to be
true in our life for the us to get there
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show